oh hi and welcome to yet another game
life now if you're like me you've
probably been sitting around wondering
what in the blue heck you're supposed to
do with your Nintendo 3ds look games are
coming for this thing I swear it it's
just that publishers are taking their
sweet time but Sega and Square Enix are
both about to solve your 3ds gaming
blues musically since I am very bad at
spending money I imported the Japanese
versions so now I can tell you all about
Sega's Rhythm Thief and Square Enix is
Theatrhythm Final Fantasy Rhythm Thief
is what would happen if professor layton
and Rhythm Heaven had a baby but then
put that baby in an orphanage it's
lacking in parental guidance you're a
famous cat burglar who solves mysteries
in the city of Paris France you spend
half the game wandering the city tapping
the screen to find secrets and talking
to people to get clues occasionally
instead of solving logic puzzles like
Professor Layton you'll play a music
game like Rhythm Heaven to advance the
story these are call and response games
you listen to the music as it plays and
tap out the appropriate rhythms the
music can be very catchy and the games
that involve tapping the buttons or
tapping the touchscreen are fun and
challenging rhythm thief's problem is
the games that require you to rotate the
3ds in rhythm these are just
infuriatingly imprecise and should have
been gotten rated and then there's
Theatrhythm Final Fantasy the game with
the worst possible name more of a dance
dance revelution or rock band style game
in which a stream of notes moves across
the screen and you have to tap and swipe
with the stylus to match the pattern of
beats it's not that different from any
other rhythm games except for the fact
that it's full of Final Fantasy music
from the series 13 main games comes 5
musical numbers each which you play in
order that scenes from the games play
out in the background it's like a trip
down memory lane for role-playing game
nerds you're reliving 25 years of Final
Fantasy games through the music there's
a lot of gameplay here once you've
finished playing the songs in the normal
difficulty
the challenge mode which is very
difficult you can also level up your
characters like an RPG the more that you
play which gives you more hit points
which allows you to miss more notes in
the harder songs while staying alive my
main complaint about theater than Final
Fantasy besides that horrible name is
the fact that it uses all the original
soundtrack music even from the old 8-bit
games it's a nice dose of nostalgia but
but these these pieces of music they're
just like 20-second loops of MIDI that
go over and over again but Square Enix
should have done in this case was use
some of the orchestrated music that they
have on file which would have given it
much more of an impact
so while neither of these two rhythm
games are perfect fans of the music
genre can keep their toes tapping with
their 3ds this July that's it for this
episode of game life we will see you
next week